dude there seems to be a big trend right
now with with people coming to youtubers
houses oh yeah they can add the amount
of tweets I've seen in the past two
weeks being like guys you know I love
making videos for you guys and I hate to
get serious here but please don't come
to my house they're all structured the
exact same you know what I mean yeah
yeah we um well what what the [ __ ]
no one has busted in our place yet yeah
I know that's not a challenge though
that's not a challenge I'm gonna end up
between the same [ __ ] guys really didn't
think I'd have to say this but please
keep coming to my house please keep
coming to my house it's awesome I love
it I love it look in my windows watch me
at all times no don't don't do that
oh and I just kind of just I like those
tweets when I see him I'm just like it's
just they're always just like my dog is
really scared my wife is scared please
don't come to my house what a 15 year
old who the camera I mean it is [ __ ]
creepy man it is creepy but I also kind
of its kind of bold kind of bold is to
show it there's a pull-up with a camera
yeah it happened one time at my old
place oh yeah and some girl was just
like standing outside of the gate just
looking and I was like can I help you
she was like yeah um I'm a big fan and I
was just while I was just walking around
the neighborhood with my mom and like
just you know this is and she tried to
play it off like it like it was just by
chance yeah but she was standing at my
gate as I came out this and then her mom
was there too her mom like like walked
into the frame and was like hey hi sorry
you mind if my daughter gets a picture
and I was like you brought your [ __ ]
kid here what part of you thinks that's
okay honestly kind of hard you should
have invited them inside yeah yeah yeah
you guys want some tea or some [ __ ] you
should man you should have gave them a
copy of your key actually open-door
policy keep it unlocks come on in
whenever you want
guys please stop coming on my house
really didn't think I'd have to say this
but the semen is messing with the paint
I need you to stop jacking off on my
house please stop [ __ ] on my house
no come la casa beating off on a
sprinkler I don't know why people keep
jerking off hey hey hey I'm almost done
just give me two more say hey scram
no scram Dave you did it you finish you
better clean up all this jizz we should
do a video with Steve Oh like that
someone take that clip someone please
just take that clip post on Twitter
brothers yeah we should just get with
steve-o and do a tour where we go beat
off on every youtubers house you know
everyone comes to your house but no one
comes on your house
it's a good way to just get everybody's
attention we go to cook we could talk
about that actually I don't know if
you're going to talk about this what was
it
I just I I wanted to let that marinate
though what was your hand in the air and
that'll be a good out-of-context clip
now you're trying to distract from yours
no no no yeah you are no we can keep the
come on the house bit going I like that
bit actually I like coming on the house
that's good I like that one a lot
there's something really funny about
she's locking eyes with someone don't
you [ __ ] come don't you come what are
you gonna do about it don't you do it
don't you I love you don't you do it God
if you come here I favorite you're my
favorite youtuber you're my favorite
cheese right now
oh you're my favorite oh there it goes
oh you're my favorite
please please have it have it oh so you
rubbing it on the house have all of it
[Laughter]
Susan Baratheon here at CBS 9 what
happened here earlier today I I don't
know I came out and normal day walk took
take my dog for a walk I came out and
locked eyes with this young man cut Cody
wasn't the only one who came out and
this guy was cranking his hog harder
than I've ever seen twenty-nine-year-old
dobre brother Michael dobre was jerking
off on Cody's house and before I knew it
before I could even say anything to this
man because my big thing was don't like
jerking off one thing totally fine I get
people need to do that but don't you
come don't you dare don't you dare blow
your load statistics show that men who
jerk off are likely to have a lower IQ
this is linked to a study and then we
just take it a whole other direction
there's nothing to do looking there's
nothing to do it there'll be this big
roundabout story about low IQ was
jacking off semen and this and that and
then it comes right back to and then he
just came on my house I knew it all over
the place
[Music]